[Musique]
J'avais l'habitude de me poser beaucoup de questions
Scott tu es à l'ex-détenu
comment es-tu un Avenger ça n'a aucun
sens
mais partout où je vais les gens me disent la
même chose merci Spiderman les
gens ont toujours besoin d'aide papa c'est  pourquoi nous avons
fait cela
comme un satellite pour l'espace
lointain mais Quanah attends une minute tu envoies
un signal vers le royaume quantique
éteignez-le
maintenant
[Musique]
où
sommes-nous
écoutons mon propre esprit c'est l'
univers secret sous le nôtre
quels sont  tu as tellement peur
qu'il y a quelque chose que je ne t'ai jamais dit que
ce n'est pas ce que tu penses
[Musique]
Je peux te ramener à la maison
et te donner plus de temps
si tu m'aides
alors